Anyways, we're down, we're down, nobody cares. Nobody cares. Did we lose listeners over the AI hot take? Certainly, 100%. I don't know whether I can find somebody senior to bring in here who's going to be a good culture fit for the team and like have the right energy for like this like new like shifting, changing evolving landscape. And my hot take is, and like him and I talked about this a little bit, my hot take is not
反正，我们掉粉了，我们掉粉了，没人关心的。没人关心的。我们是不是因为那个关于AI的犀利言论而流失听众了？肯定的，百分之百。我不知道能不能在公司找个资深的人来，既能很好地融入团队文化，又能在这种类似全新的、转变中的、不断演进的局势里带来对的活力。而我的犀利言论是，而且我和他稍微聊过这个，我的犀利言论不是
everyone's going to make it. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 287 recorded on May 5th, 2006. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we continue and conclude our chat with Marco. In this episode, we chat about all things AI. We get an AI hot take from Bryce, and we discuss whether we should let AI do your taxes. All right, everybody's recording now, and we're recording in the meeting. Bryce was already recording when he joined, and so he started talking.
所有人都能熬过这一关。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 287 期，录制于 2006 年 5 月 5 日。我是康纳，今天与我的联合主持人布赖斯一起，我们将继续并结束与马尔科的聊天。在本期节目中，我们畅聊了关于 AI 的一切。我们听取了布赖斯对 AI 的犀利看法，并讨论了我们是否应该让 AI 帮我们报税。好了，大家现在都在录音了，而且我们在会议中也在录音。布赖斯加入时就已经在录音了，所以他开始说话了，
and we'll let him continue to talk. But before we do that, we have to, because when I was editing last time, at one point we were going to let Marco tell us a little bit about MV comp, but I interrupted to get more details on his path to Nvidia and not having been programming like a few years ago. And then we never came back to MV comp. So one, just put it on the stack. It doesn't need to be at the beginning, can be at the end.
我们会让他继续说下去。但在那之前，我们必须——因为上次剪辑时，有一段我们本打算让马尔科跟我们讲讲 MV comp，但我打断了他，想了解更多关于他加入英伟达的经历，以及他几年前根本没怎么编程的事情。然后我们再也没回到 MV comp 这个话题上。所以第一，把它记在待办栈里。它不需要在开头，可以放在结尾。
We'll put MV comp on. We also did get one, or technically, I think two questions from a single listener that we will put on the stack as well. So there's a couple topics on the stack, actually, and while we're at it, we'll put the second implementation of the GPU rotate, which everybody is waiting for. That's the third item on the stack.
我们会把 MV comp 放上去。我们还收到了一个，严格来说，我觉得是一个听众提出的两个问题，我们也会把它们放到待办栈里。所以待办栈里其实有好几个话题，趁着现在，我们把 GPU 旋转的第二个实现也放上去，大家都期待着呢。那是待办栈里的第三项。
All right, now over to Bryce. Feel free to tell us what you were telling us. Hang on. Hang on. I got to finish typing the thing to my agent. All right, now he's busy. Now he's busy with AI. That's the thing I was going to tell you
好了，现在把时间交给布赖斯。请畅所欲言，讲讲你刚才要说的事。等一下。等一下。我得把给我的智能体（Agent）打字输完。好吧，他现在正忙着呢。他现在正忙着搞 AI 呢。我要跟你说的是，
is like, I just got back from dinner, like sat down, got on this call to start, recording and at the same time I was like I got a I got to check how things are going I think that's the problem kind of that before if you wanted to get some sort of work done there was a hurdle because it's like okay if I want to do something I have to spend some time getting back into whatever I want to do and getting acquainted with what I was doing and so it takes a couple of minutes half an hour so you can't just hop in do work for 10 minutes or you couldn't and now you can because it's like okay what was my agent doing what do I have to
就像我刚刚吃完晚饭，坐下来，加入这个通话准备开始录音，与此同时我觉得“我得去看看进展怎么样了”。我觉得这可能就是问题所在，以前如果你想完成某种工作，是有一道门槛的，因为你会觉得，好吧，如果我想做点什么，我得花点时间重新进入我想做的状态，熟悉我之前在做什么，所以这需要花几分钟到半小时不等，你不能只是随便跳进去工作 10 分钟——或者说以前不能，但现在可以了，因为你可以想：我的智能体在干什么？我必须
it now so that it keeps working. So you can fit everything in in five minutes. And I think that's what makes it so intense now. That's actually one question that I wanted to ask you guys is how you're dealing with context switching because I find it that now it's so exhausting, so much more exhausting than six months ago. Yeah, I mean, I would say it's less than five minutes sometimes. Like last night. So today is May 5th, tail end of the day. Well, I mean, it's very much the tail end of the day for Marco because you're over in Europe. Actually, yeah, what conference are at you at, Bryce? I'm at Go Sim in Paris. Go Sim? Yeah. It's some sort of agentic conference.
现在处理它，这样它才能继续工作。所以你可以把所有事情塞进短短五分钟里。我觉得这正是让它变得如此紧张激烈的原因。其实我一直想问你们一个问题，就是你们是怎么处理上下文切换的，因为我发现现在的上下文切换太让人精疲力竭了，比六个月前累多了。对，我的意思是，有时候甚至不到五分钟。比如昨晚。所以今天是 5 月 5 日，接近一天结束的时候。好吧，对马尔科来说确实是接近一天结束，因为你在欧洲。说起来，布赖斯，你参加的是什么会议？我在巴黎的 Go Sim 大会。Go Sim？对。某种关于智能体（Agentic）的会议。
Go Sim. All right. Well, you're in Paris. All right. So both of you, it's a tail end on East Coast still. Let me do a better. It's an agenic AI conference. I don't know what Go Sim stands for. I'm sure I could be a better job. It's pretty good. So last night was May 4th, may the 4th be with you. And for the hardcore Star Wars fans out there, which includes me now, maybe not a couple years ago, but now I'm a massive fan. It was the two episodes season finale of Mall Shadow Lord available on Disney Plus, and I think
Go Sim。好吧。你在巴黎。好，所以对你们俩来说，东海岸这边还处于一天快结束的时候。让我说得更好点。这是一个智能体 AI 会议。我不知道 Go Sim 代表什么。我肯定能表现得更好。挺不错的。所以昨晚是 5 月 4 日，“愿原力与你同在”（May the 4th be with you）。对于那些硬核星球大战粉丝来说，其中现在也包括我，可能几年前还不是，但现在我是个超级粉丝。那是《曼达洛人与古古》（Mall Shadow Lord）的双集季终集，在 Disney Plus 上线，我想
that's the only place you can get it. And my wife, beautiful wife and I were watching last night, and she is also a huge Star Wars fan now. And I can't remember if it definitely wasn't in. in between episode nine and 10. I sat on the couch for that, but at some point, I think we were watching John Stewart right before that,
那是唯一能看的地方。我美丽的妻子和我昨晚在看，她现在也是个超级粉丝了。我不记得是不是在第九集和第十集之间了。我当时为了那个坐在沙发上，但在某个时刻，我想我们刚好在那之前在看乔恩·斯图尔特（John Stewart），
and then I got up to get like, you know, a bubbly or something, and then I was like, I went up the stairs, and she's like, where are you going? And I was like, I just want to go check on Codex real quick, just real quick, just like 30 seconds to see if it's still iterating, because now I've gotten into the habit of, like, coaxing it into basically, it'll only launch six subagents at a time, but if you tell it like, you know,
然后我起身去拿点气泡水什么的，接着我上了楼，她就问：“你去哪儿？”我说：“我只想去快速检查一下 Codex，就一小会儿，大概 30 秒，看看它还在不在迭代。”因为我现在已经养成了一种习惯，比如诱导它基本上——它一次只能启动 6 个子智能体，但如果你告诉它，比如说，
queue up 100 sub-agents, and as soon as like one is done, just like launch another one and keep launching them, and you just tell it, like, I'm going to step away for a couple, I'm going to go have dinner, I'm going to be away for a couple hours,
排队 100 个子智能体，一旦其中一个完成，就立刻启动另一个，并不断启动它们，然后你告诉它：“我要离开一会儿，我要去吃晚饭，我要离开几个小时，
but I don't want you to stop working while I'm gone. A lot of the times, if you tell it the right incantation, it'll just keep working while you're gone. And if you get that incantation correct, you can just pop upstairs, check to see if it's stopped, look at the work for like 10 seconds,
但我不想在我离开的时候你停止工作。”很多时候，如果你用了正确的咒语，它就会在你离开的时候一直工作下去。如果你把那个咒语用对了，你就可以跑到楼上，检查它是否停下来，看上 10 秒钟的工作成果，
commit it, and then like hit the up arrow key, launch the same magic command, and then poof, it's back off to the races for another couple, hours. And so the point being is, do you even need five minutes? And my wife was like, what? No, no, no, we're done work. And I was like, I'm not going to do work. Do you not know about stop hook, by the way, Connor? Do I not know about what? Most of the harnesses have hooks that have on certain events, like if it tries to read a file or
提交它，然后敲一下向上箭头键，启动相同的魔法命令，然后——噗——它又开足马力运行另外好几个小时了。所以重点是，你甚至需要五分钟吗？我老婆当时就说：“什么？不，不，不，我们已经下班了。”我说：“我这不是在工作。”康纳，你难道不知道有停止钩子（stop hook）这回事吗？我不知道什么？大多数代码框架都有钩子，可以在某些事件发生时触发，比如如果它试图读取文件，或者
if it tries to stop. So you can just install a stop hook that tells it to keep going. If you want to keep going hook. It's not, it's not stopping on anything. It's just concluding that it's done, it's finished doing the task that I assigned it. I warn you to be very careful with this because it can end up in a loop where it just sends a short response of I'm done. And then the stop hook triggers, no, you're not. And then it just loops on that forever. And that's very token wasteful. But aside from that problem, it's very useful.
如果它试图停止。所以你只需安装一个停止钩子，告诉它继续运行。如果你想要一个继续运行的钩子。它不是在任何事情上停止。它只是得出结论说它完成了，完成了我分配给它的任务。我警告你一定要非常小心这个，因为它最后可能会陷入一个循环，只发回一个简短的回复说“我完成了”。然后停止钩子触发：不，你没有。接着它就会永远在这个循环里死循环。这非常浪费 Token。但除了这个问题之外，它非常有用。
I'm working on figuring out how to get past that. Yeah. Anyways, I didn't answer your question, Marco, but it's definitely a thing. Like, I was having dinner a couple weeks ago with a buddy of mine who works in Vancouver. And he was saying it's almost like exhausting now because, a lot of the mundane tasks that sometimes, you know, it would be a Thursday, kind of a long week, and you're just mentally tired, and you'd find that mundane task that's going to take an hour, and then, like, you'd just do that.
我正在研究怎么绕过那个问题。是的。不管怎样，我没有回答你的问题，马尔科，但这种情况确实存在。就像几周前我和一个在温哥华工作的哥们吃晚饭时，他说现在感觉简直精疲力竭，因为很多日常琐事——有时候，你知道的，刚好赶上周四，这周挺长的，你精神上已经很疲惫了，你会发现那些本需要花一个小时的日常琐事，然后，你就直接把它们处理了。
Now, like, those mundane tasks, they're gone. They've evaporated. So all that you have to do now is, like, hard thinking work. And it's hard to do that, like, constantly, where you're going to sit down and you know that, like, the work that you're going to do is, like, I'm going to have to sit here and really think about the structure or, you know. you know, it's not easy work. And so you find yourself mentally exhausted, like a lot quicker because there's no, like,
现在呢，那些日常琐事全都消失了。它们蒸发了。所以你现在要做的全部工作，都是硬核的思考工作。要一直这样干很难，你坐下来，明知你要做的工作是那种“我必须坐在这里，认真思考架构”之类的事情，你知道这可不是轻松的工作。所以你会发现自己精神上的疲惫来得更快，因为根本没有像
updating the docs or changing some markdown file, like all that stuff. I feel amped. I feel amped all the time, Connor. I'm not saying I feel exhausted. But when he was saying that, there are definitely times where, like, Friday rolls around. And I do feel like more, like, mentally zapped than, you know, the before times. And so how do we deal with this? I don't know.
更新文档或者修改某个 Markdown 文件之类的事了。我整个人处于亢奋状态。我一直都很亢奋，康纳。我不是说我感到精疲力竭。但当他说那番话时，确实有时候到了周五，
You go for more runs. Yeah. I don't know, Bryce. I guess Bryce is amps, so he doesn't have any issues with this. I'm building things, Connor. Yeah. I mean, you showed me what you're working on. Yeah, we can't talk about it yet until it's done on the podcast.
我确实感觉比以前的日子精神被榨得更干。那我们该怎么应对呢？我不知道。
But like, I don't know, I'm pretty close to having the orchestration layer set up. And then we can start doing the real fun stuff. But I think like, I want to say like two weeks, two weeks maybe. Yeah. Have you guys heard of, I do think that I'm like 75, 25, 25 in the, 75 just so amped, like, it's hard to fall asleep because you're so excited, which is interesting because I've listened to some podcasts that say the opposite, like, that they're the exact opposite.
多去跑步。对啊。我不知道，布赖斯，我猜布赖斯很亢奋，所以他在这方面没有任何问题。我在创造东西，康纳。对啊。我的意思是，你给我看你在做什么了。对，我们在播客里还不能谈论它，直到它完成。
They've never been less motivated before in their careers because, like, AI is taking a lot of this work. I find myself the opposite, and it's just like, and I was listening to a couple podcasts that we're talking about what Arnda Carpathie was talking about. I don't know, I'll link it in the show notes. But he was talking about, like, this idea of, like, neural computing, and it's just, it's to be like just in time apps and like just in time websites. And like I completely see that being the future. Like just the other day I added some feature where I could sort my race times. Like I have a
不过，我觉得，我离把编排层（orchestration layer）搭建好已经不远了。然后我们就可以开始做真正好玩的东西了。但我觉得，我想大概两周吧，两周左右。对。你们听说过吗，我觉得我大概是 75% 对 25%，那种 75% 的状态超级亢奋，以至于因为太兴奋而难以入睡，这很有趣，因为我听过一些播客持完全相反的观点，他们说自己截然相反。
website that lists all of my 5K, 10K, half and marathon times over the last like decade plus. And I had a half marathon over the weekend. It didn't go well. And I wanted to know like what was the, what was the ranking of this in the 27 like half marathons I've run in my lifetime? And so, like, I'm not going to go and, like, manually eyeball it. Like, that's impossible. So I just went to cursor and was like, hey, add like a sort mechanism so that when I'm filtering, if I hit, if I just click on the header of this column, just immediately sort it. And then I said also, too, once it's in sorting mode, inject a basically column that shows
他们在职业生涯中从未像现在这样缺乏动力，因为 AI 抢走了大量的工作。我发现自己恰恰相反，而且就像——我听了几个播客在讨论安德烈·卡帕西（Andrej Karpathy）谈论的内容。不管怎样，我会在节目文稿里放个链接。他谈到了神经计算的概念，它将变成即时应用（just-in-time apps）和即时网站（just-in-time websites）。我完全能看到那将是未来。就在前几天，我添加了一个功能，可以让我对自己的比赛成绩进行排序。我有个人
you one, two, three, four, five, because it didn't have the numbering. Sure enough, one shot at that. And, like, why do I have to sit down at a computer, launch a cursor instance, and, like, tell it, that's what I want. Like, in the future. you're going to be able to talk to this website and it's going to just in time generate you like a version
网站，上面列了我过去十年多来所有的 5 公里、10 公里、半马和全马成绩。我周末跑了个半马。成绩不太好。我想知道在我这辈子跑过的 27 场半马里，这次排第几？所以，我才不会去手动用肉眼看呢。那是不可能的。所以我直接打开 Cursor 软件说：“嘿，加个排序机制，这样当我筛选时，如果我点击这列的表头，就能立即对其排序。”然后我还说，一旦进入排序模式，就插入一个基本上能显示一、二、三、四、五的列，因为之前没有编号。果不其然，一次搞定。然后，为什么我非得坐在电脑前，启动一个 Cursor 实例，然后告诉它那就是我想要的？未来，
or like an edited thing where it's just say like and you can imagine like being an Android auto like in your car you're driving and like all the time what I want is like show me all of the restaurants that are open like past you know 930 p.m. that are within like a five clock.
你将能够直接和这个网站对话，它就会即时为你生成一个版本，或者像是一个编辑过的东西，上面就写着——你可以想象一下，就像在车里使用 Android Auto 一样，你在开车，而我一直想要的是：给我显示所有晚上 9:30 以后仍在营业、并且在五分钟车程内的餐馆。
It is terrible at that right now. Like it cannot tell you for the life of it like what's open currently especially like if I want a specific type of muffin you know that should be a thing in the future. It should be able to identify every single restaurant Why do you think it's bad at this? Oh, it's just terrible.
它现在在这方面烂透了。它根本无法告诉你当前到底有什么开着，尤其是如果我想找某种特定的松饼的话，你知道的，未来这应该是个标配。它应该能够识别出每一个餐馆。你觉得为什么它在这方面这么烂？哦，简直烂透了。
When you are, why? Why? Why? Because it has not figured out to like hook. And also too, Google Maps in general. Like how do you query Google Maps? Say I'm driving from, you know,
当你——为什么？为什么？为什么？因为它还没搞懂怎么去进行挂钩（hook）。还有，谷歌地图也是整体如此。比如你怎么查询谷歌地图？比方说我在从……
I will say, I will say, listen, I don't, I, I, I, I, I, my Twitter takes have gotten a little bit spicier recently. And I hate to use this platform to shit on Gemini, but I just have to. I tweet, so I had this thing where like I needed to ask, I needed to update some calendar invites. I needed to add a person, like invite a person to some Google calendar invites, and then I wanted to change the color of a bunch of Google calendar invites. It was like a pretty simple ask. I sent the prompt to Gemini from like, you know, my Google calendar page. Because there's a little Gemini button on my Google calendar page. And it was immediately, it was just like,
我要说，我要说，听着，我，我，我，我，我最近在 Twitter 上的言论变得有点尖锐了。我讨厌利用这个平台来吐槽 Gemini，但我实在忍不住。我发推文说，我有这么个需求，需要修改一些日历邀请。我需要加一个人，比如邀请一个人加入一些谷歌日历邀请，然后我想批量更改一堆谷歌日历邀请的颜色。这是一个非常简单的请求。我从——你知道的——我的谷歌日历页面向 Gemini 发送了提示词。因为我的谷歌日历页面上有一个小的 Gemini 按钮。它立刻就表现得像，
I can't do that. And then I went to chat GPT and I did the same prompt and chat TPT, which, what company makes chat GPT again, Connor? Open AI. Right, right. And who makes Google Calendar? Google? That's right. That's right.
我做不到。然后我去了 ChatGPT，发了同样的提示词，而 ChatGPT——是哪家公司制造了 ChatGPT 来着，康纳？OpenAI。对，没错。那谁制造了谷歌日历？谷歌？没错。正是如此。
Right. And so ChatGPT's Google Calendar integration worked perfectly in the first time. And so now, like, it's actually really good. Like, I've been doing all my calendar management from the Google Calendar-like plugin thing in ChatGPT. But every time I try to use Google's AI to do anything with Google's products, it sucks. It's terrible. It's just absolutely awful. It can't do anything in Excel.
没错。所以 ChatGPT 的谷歌日历集成一次就完美运行了。所以现在，实际上它真的很好用。我一直在用 ChatGPT 里的谷歌日历插件来管理我所有的日历。但每次我试图用谷歌的 AI 去做任何与谷歌产品相关的事情时，它都很逊。它烂透了。简直糟糕透顶。它在 Excel 里什么也做不了，
It can't do anything in email. It can't do anything with my calendar. First of all, it's Sheets, not Excel. Excel's a Microsoft product. I don't want to be the pedantic guy on the podcast, but Excel is from Microsoft. Google Sheets is from Google. And you're thinking that's a distinction without a difference,
它在电子邮件里什么也做不了。它对我的日历也无能为力。首先，那是 Sheets，不是 Excel。Excel 是微软的产品。我不想在播客里当那个死板纠错的人，但 Excel 是微软的。谷歌表格（Google Sheets）是谷歌的。而你觉得这俩没啥区别，
big difference, folks. And I haven't really tried to do much with integrating stuff. And in general, I don't use ChachyPT anymore because it's just terrible. That being said, Gemini has been offline all day. What do you mean? GPD 5.5 is great. 5.5 is amazing, but like if you're just using it as like a free user going to like the web app to ask some question, I gave up on Chad GPT like months ago because. You're not,
区别可大了，各位。而且我其实没怎么尝试过去集成各种东西。总的来说，我不再用 ChatGPT 了，因为它实在太烂了。话虽如此，Gemini 这一整天都在宕机。你什么意思？GPT 5.5 太棒了。5.5 惊艳无比，但如果你只是作为一个免费用户去网页端问个问题，我几个月前就放弃 ChatGPT 了，因为……你不是，
you're still not paying for a Jad GPD subscription? I don't want to pay for like if it's just simple questions. Like if I want to know how to convert some Fahrenheit to Celsius or I want some random thing. I'm not going to tell you about my cloud bill for all the various stuff I've been building this. Also, too, I don't want to be using my corporate account for like personal questions, you know? Like if I'm, if I'm looking for muffins, I don't need a video knowing that I'm... I don't use my... Like, I have personal subscription to chat GPT and actually to Gemini.
你居然还是没为 ChatGPT 订阅付费？如果只是简单的问题，我才不想花钱呢。比如我想知道怎么把华氏度转换成摄氏度，或者想查点乱七八糟的事。我才不会跟你唠我在搞这些乱七8糟的东西时产生的云服务账单呢。还有，我也不想用公司的账号来问私人问题，懂吧？如果我在找松饼，我可不需要英伟达知道我……我不用我的……我个人订阅了 ChatGPT，其实还有 Gemini。
Although, you know what? I'm really... I really should make a note to go cancel that Gemini subscription. It's so funny because everyone's like anecdotal experience. They have one bad experience. They go look at Gemini and Gemini happens to be better that day. And now I've been using Gemini for the past. But like Bryce is saying that, you know, chat, GPT,
不过，你知道吗？我真的……我真的该记下来去取消那个 Gemini 订阅了。太搞笑了，因为每个人的体验都是道听途说。他们有了一次糟糕的体验，然后去看 Gemini，而 Gemini 那天刚好表现得更好。于是我过去这段时间一直在用 Gemini……但就像布赖斯说的，ChatGPT，
is way better. I have no commentary on the quality of the model itself, but my default has been to use chat GPT for all my chat like tasks. And the times when I've tried to use Google's AI has been when I've needed to do something that involved tool use with Google's product. And it sucks. It's so bad. Yeah.
好得多。我对模型本身的质量不做评论，但我默认所有类似聊天的任务都用 ChatGPT。而我尝试使用谷歌 AI 的时候，都是因为我需要做一些涉及谷歌产品工具调用的事情。这太烂了。太糟糕了。是的。
I don't know. What's your experience, Marco? What are you, what are your, I mean, both you can answer your own question and then, do you prefer Gemini, chat GPT, none of the above? You're just sitting up outside touching grass and enjoying life. I've been using perplexity. For my web-based stuff, I use perplexity because you can choose the model according to what's the best at the moment.
我不知道。你的体验如何，马尔科？你，你的……我是说，你们俩既可以回答自己的问题，然后，你更喜欢 Gemini、ChatGPT 还是以上都不是？你只是坐在户外摸鱼享受生活吗？我一直在用 Perplexity。对于网络搜索相关的内容，我用 Perplexity，因为你可以根据当前哪个模型最好来选择模型。
And for me, I mean, whenever I need to look something up on the internet, it's more than good enough. And then for coding, I'm still with ClodCode. I've been seeing that apparently Codex and GPD5.5 is supposedly better, but I don't know, cloud code works well enough for me, and I'd rather just stick with that because who knows, maybe in two months, another model comes from Anthropic, and it's now better than 5.5, and I don't want to be switching between Codex and ClodCode all the time, because I have also my conversations. You're not thinking big enough. The reason why you need to be multi-harness and multi-model is because
对我来说，呃，每当我需要在网上查东西时，它已经好得绰绰有余了。至于写代码，我还是在用 Claude Code。我看到有消息说 Codex 和 GPT-5.5 好像更好，但怎么说呢，Claude Code 对我来说已经足够好用了，我宁愿就坚持用它，因为谁知道呢，也许两个月后 Anthropic 又会推出另一个模型，现在比 5.5 更好了，我可不想一直在 Codex 和 Claude Code 之间切换，因为我还有我的对话历史。你想得还不够宏大。你需要多平台、多模型的原因是
when you start using this stuff enough, you're going to run out of your corporate token rate. And sure, I could go and ask for more. But my whole, like, I just want to move fast. I don't want to be down for, like, a day or two or three days because I need to explain to people why I need a hundred million more, you know, tokens or whatever. You know, so, like, I have, like, I now have, like a system, like a cascading system of various different ways that I can get inference from NVIDIA, where, like, the worst case is, like, I go spin up some B200 nodes on Brev and just, like,
当你开始大量使用这些东西时，你的企业额度会用完。当然，我可以去申请更多。但我的整个理念是，我只想快速推进。我不想因为需要向别人解释为什么我需要多一亿个代币之类的原因而停工一天、两天或三天。所以，呃，比如我现在有了一套系统，一个包含各种不同途径的级联系统，我可以从英伟达获取推理能力，最坏的情况是，比如我去 Brev 上启动一些 B200 节点，然后，
serve myself Deepseek V4 Pro or something. Like one of the quantized versions that'll fit on like a B200. Yeah. So yeah, you got to have like a strategy, like, you know, a fallback scheme in case your preferred model is not available. I'm not that big of a token abuser. You really destroy the cloud code tokens instead of like a month? I think I'll, I think I will run out of, I don't think I should say what like the
自己运行 Deepseek V4 Pro 之类的模型。比如某个能塞进 B200 的量化版本。是的。所以，是的，你必须制定一个策略，比如，如果你的首选模型不可用时的备用方案。我可不是那种超级代币消耗大户。你真的在一个月内就把 Claude Code 的代币用完了吗？我想我会，我想我会用完的，我觉得我不该透露
Nvidia cap is on like dollar spend like by default. But I'm already in the power user group and yes, I think I will expend it because like not not right now because right now I'm just putting together this orchestration system. But once I get back to actually doing like runs of stuff, yeah, I'm going to burn through it very quickly. I think that's a great nickname that you've come up with Marco for Bryce is Bryce Adelstein Lelbeck, aka the token abuser because boy oh boy, is he abusing tokens. That's for sure.
英伟达默认的美元消费上限是多少。但我已经在高级用户组里了，是的，我觉得我会用完它，因为，呃，不是现在，因为现在我只是在拼凑这个编排系统。但一旦我回到实际运行各种任务的工作中，是的，我很快就会把它烧光。我觉得你给布莱斯起的外号太棒了，马尔科，叫布莱斯·阿德尔斯坦·莱尔贝克，也就是代币消耗大户，因为天哪，他真的是在疯狂消耗代币。那是肯定的。
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. But the thing is, you know, Nvidia has this great developer crowd Brev, and it's fairly easy to get access to GPUs in Brev, except just not Blackwell GPUs. And so I have been thinking lately, like, okay, like, you know, I have all this access to this Breb compute that I can use for the various projects I'm working on.
对。对，对。但问题是，你知道，英伟达有 Brev 这个极好的开发者群体，在 Brev 里获取 GPU 相当容易，只是没有 Blackwell GPU 而已。所以我最近一直在想，好吧，比如说，你知道，我拥有所有这些 Breb 计算资源的访问权限，我可以将它们用于我正在从事的各种项目。
And so, like, in the worst case, I'll just figure out how to run on, you know, like there's a ton of H-100 availability here, so I can just run, you know, some models myself on all these H-100s, and then serve up my agents that are also running on this infrastructure. That's one of the reasons I had to pause to do this orchestration layer thing. And what do you do for Auto Run? Because you can't run Auto Run everywhere, anywhere you like. And I think that's where it really becomes powerful because having to be...
所以，在最坏的情况下，我会弄清楚如何在上面运行，你知道，这里有大量的 H-100 可用资源，所以我可以直接在所有这些 H-100 上自己运行一些模型，然后提供我的智能体服务，这些智能体也运行在这个基础设施上。这就是我不得不暂停来做这个编排层事情的原因之一。那你对自动运行有什么看法？因为你不能随心所欲地在任何地方运行自动运行。我认为这正是它真正变得强大的地方，因为必须……
Right, but Brev is one of the approved sandboxed environments for Nvidia. It's not behind the VPN. All of the stuff I'm doing, none of it has access to any Nvidia proprietary information. All the stuff I'm doing is just experiments on a certain thing we can't talk about yet, but all it requires is just my agent to be able to look at code on GitHub. It doesn't need access to anything proprietary. It doesn't have access to any. My security models is that this is running in a cloud instance.
对，但 Brev 是英伟达批准的沙盒环境之一。它不在 VPN 后面。我做的所有事情，都没有访问任何英伟达专有信息的权限。我做的所有事情都只是对某个我们还不能讨论的事情的实验，但它唯一的要求是我的智能体能够查看 GitHub 上的代码。它不需要访问任何专有内容。它不需要访问任何。我的安全模型是这运行在云实例中。
It has no credentials that can do any damage to anything. Yeah, that's definitely nice. Yes. So, I mean, I don't know if we fully answered with Marco's question. Bryce doesn't need to take a break because he's so excited. and... No, I got to take a break because I need to go
它没有任何可以对任何东西造成破坏的凭证。是的，那确实很好。是的。所以，我的意思是，我不知道我们是否完全回答了马尔科的问题。布莱斯不需要休息，因为他太兴奋了，而且……不，我得休息一下，因为我需要去
to see all this agent what to do. But yeah, I'm 75-25. And I am concerned like when I hear some of the stuff that I hear on podcasts
看看所有这些智能体该做什么。不过说真的，我是 75 对 25。而且我确实有点担心，当我听到播客里提到的一些事情时
about just the motivation of certain developers being at like all-time lows. Yeah, that is concerning to me. Can I have a hot take? All right, go ahead. I mean, of course. Actually, wait,
关于某些开发者的积极性降至历史最低点。是的，这让我很担忧。我能发表个犀利观点吗？好吧，说吧。当然，其实，等等，
this is the perfect, the perfect time. At one point, like 100 episodes ago, there was some Korean K-pop song, I was supposed to insert whenever Bryce had a hot take, boom. I just inserted it.
这正是绝佳的，绝佳的时机。在某个时候，比如 100 集以前，有一首韩国 K-pop 歌，每当布莱斯有犀利观点时我就该放这首歌，动次打次。我刚把它插进去了。
And I was talking to one of my more AI forward colleagues at our Shanghai office when I was there two weeks ago. And he's really like a very forward thinking guy. And I think he was really early in a lot of this hygienic stuff in ways that I didn't realize like a year ago. But like now I realize like, oh, he was totally ahead of the curve. And he said something about, you know, I have everybody in my team. is either an intern or a new college grad.
两周前我在上海办公室时，曾和一位更倾向于 AI 发展的同事聊过。他真的是一个非常有前瞻性的人。我觉得他在一年前就对很多这类智能体相关的东西有了很早的认识，这是我当时没有意识到的。但现在我意识到，哦，他完全走在了时代的前沿。他谈到了一些事情，比如，你知道，我团队里的所有人
And like, I have slots for senior people in my team, but I don't know how to fill them. Because, like, we're doing all this agenic stuff, and all these young kids, like, they get it. And I don't know, I don't know whether I can find somebody senior to bring in here who's going to be a good culture fit for the team and, like, have the right energy for, like, this, like, new, like, shifting, changing, evolving landscape.
要么是实习生，要么是应届大学毕业生。而且，我团队里有高级岗位的名额，但我不知道该怎么填补。因为，我们在做所有这些智能体相关的事情，所有这些年轻人，他们懂。我不知道，我不知道我是否能找到一个资深人士带进来，并且能融入团队文化，对这种全新的、不断转变、演变的环境拥有正确的活力。
And my hot take is, and, like, him, him and I talked about this a little bit. My hot take is, not everyone's going to make it. I think that there's some people in some systems and parts of our ecosystem that are very resistant to AI. And if that becomes a persistent, stubborn attitude, I don't think they're going to make it. One of the themes of this conference that I've been at has been, so it's a conference about like open source and in the agenic era. Like, oh, and maybe not open source, but it's about open models, open weight. open source in the agenic era, like open AI, basically.
我犀利的观点是，而且，我和他讨论过这一点。我犀利的观点是，并非每个人都能成功。我认为在我们的生态系统中，有一些人和一些系统非常抵制 AI。如果这成为一种顽固的、固执的态度，我认为他们是无法成功的。我参加的这次会议的一个主题一直是，这是一个关于开源以及智能体时代的会议。比如，哦，也许不是开源，而是关于开放模型、开放权重、智能体时代的开源，基本上就像 OpenAI 一样。
Not the company open AI, but, you know, open space AI. And one thing that keeps coming up is like, you know, our existing open source licenses make sense for, like, in this era. Like, what does open source licensing mean when all the code is generated by these models that were trained on all the code in the world that has varieties of different models? And then like the other thing that came up in a conversation today was this idea that like, open, and this has come a couple times, is open source dead?
不是OpenAI这家公司，而是，你知道的，开源AI。有一个不断浮现的问题是，你知道的，我们现有的开源许可证在这个时代还合理吗？当所有的代码都是由这些模型生成的时候，开源许可证意味着什么？这些模型本身就是用世界上所有各种不同模型的代码训练出来的。然后，今天在对话中出现的另一件事是这样一个观点，这已经出现过好几次了，那就是开源死了吗？
You know, could open source be dead? There's a lot of these projects that are saying we don't want open source contributions. Like, no, no, we're not accepting any open source contributions or we're only accepting contributions from people within the team. The trend line that I'm seeing,
你知道，开源会死吗？有许多这样的话，说我们不想要开源贡献。比如，不，不，我们不接受任何开源贡献，或者我们只接受来自团队内部人员的贡献。我看到的趋势线是，
I think that saying, oh, we're not, we're using zero AI, we're not accepting any open source contributions. That's like saying, oh, we're not using version control. Like, no, we just, we don't use version control. That's not how we work. It's an unstoppable force. It's a, it's a change in the way that we work. And I think that if projects in systems and communities and people don't adapt, they may be left behind. And you and I, Connor, I think, had talked about this, about this idea that, like, it's hard, it's getting harder and harder to talk to colleagues who are AI skeptics. Like, to the degree that, like, if somebody is an AI, is AI skeptical, I almost can't have a meaningful conversation with them because the way in which I've worked has changed so much, the philosophy of how I've worked has changed so much that like
我认为，说什么“哦，我们不用任何AI，我们不接受任何开源贡献”。这就好比说，“哦，我们不用版本控制。不，我们就是不用版本控制，我们不是这样工作的。”这是一股势不可挡的力量，这是我们工作方式的变革。我认为，如果项目、系统、社群和人们不适应，他们可能会被抛在后面。康纳，你和我，我想，我们曾讨论过这个观点，即，与那些对AI持怀疑态度的同事沟通变得越来越难。以至于如果有人对AI持怀疑态度，我几乎无法与他们进行有意义的对话，因为我工作的方式已经发生了如此巨大的变化，我工作背后的理念也发生了如此巨大的变化，以至于
we're talking about two different jobs. We're talking on two different timescales of what's possible. We're talking using two completely different tool sets. And so it's like if they don't believe, if they just reject everything about what I'm doing, how can I have a meaningful conversation with them? And like, I'm not saying that everybody has to be as AI gung-ho as you or I are. But I think if you just believe that this is something that you can just, oh, it's a trend, it's got to blow over, or that you don't have to have, like, a real legitimate plan for how you're going to adapt to this world. If you just are denying it and think it's going to blow over, I think you're going to get left behind. That's my hot text.
我们在谈论两份不同的工作。我们在讨论可能性时基于两个不同的时间尺度。我们使用的完全是两套不同的工具。所以这就像，如果他们不相信，如果他们只是拒绝我所做的一切，我怎么能与他们进行有意义的对话呢？而且，我不是说每个人都必须像你或我那样对AI充满热情。但我认为，如果你只是相信这只是一种你可以认为“哦，这只是一阵风，风头会过去的”事情，或者你认为你不需要针对如何适应这个世界制定一个真正合理的计划。如果你只是在否认它，认为它会过去，我认为你会被抛在后面。这就是我的激烈观点。
So, I mean, I'm interested, Marco, to get your thoughts on this as well. But, like, so I want to just reframe a little bit of, like, yes, we had that conversation. And let me put my biases if you are for somehow stumbling across his podcast for the first time. Bryce and I, and it sounds like Marco as well, but he can speak for himself. We're massive fans. I love AI. It's making, it's change in my life. Absolutely love it.
所以，我的意思是，马可，我也很想听听你的想法。但是，我想重新构思一下，是的，我们确实有过那次对话。如果有人恰好第一次听到这个播客，请让我表明我的偏见。布莱斯和我，听起来马可也是这样，但他可以为自己发言。我们是狂热的粉丝。我爱AI。它正在改变我的生活，我绝对爱死它了。
And it's, I don't think there are a ton of people that think it's like a fad. and it's going to blow over anymore. I think everybody is seeing they've tried, you know, since basically December of 2025, they've tried either GPT or the Anthropic models and they've seen that these things are useful. I think now, though, it's people coming to the realization, like, maybe we should get this guy on.
而且，我不认为还有很多人认为这只是一种时尚，风头很快就会过去。我认为每个人都看到，他们已经尝试过了，你知道，基本上从2025年12月起，他们尝试了GPT或Anthropic的模型，他们看到这些东西是有用的。不过，我认为现在人们开始意识到，也许我们应该把这家伙请上节目。
So I randomly saw this YouTube video. I think it had like either less than 100 views or less than like 1,000 views when I first saw it. I'm not subscribed to the guy. I have no idea why, YouTube recommended it to me, but I watched it and it was interesting. And it was basically a guy, he's a Zig developer. I won't know his name off the top of my head.
所以我偶然看到了这个YouTube视频。当我第一次看到它时，它好像只有不到100次观看，或者不到1000次观看。我没有订阅这个频道。我不知道为什么YouTube会向我推荐它，但我看了，它很有趣。基本上是一个人，他是一个Zig开发者。我一下子记不起他的名字了。
And he has a small YouTube channel with like a couple thousand subscribers. And he had been working on a, I want to say, source control, like an alternative to get plus or minus. You know, the details don't really matter. But he basically quit his job, worked on it for two years and hadn't really gotten the amount of interest in it that he would have liked. And so now he basically just posted. this video saying that he kind of feels a bit lost because he, you know, left his job in order
他有一个小型YouTube频道，只有几千名订阅者。他一直在开发一个，我想说是源码控制的东西，类似于git加减的版本。你知道，细节其实并不重要。但他基本上辞去了工作，为此工作了两年，并没有真正获得他所希望的关注度。所以现在他基本上只是发布了这段视频，说他感到有点迷失，因为他为了开发这个东西而辞去了工作，
to work on this thing. And now AI's here and AI's basically replicating like half of the open source stuff out there. Is open source dead? That's an interesting question. Like, I don't think these models would be possible, or at least they wouldn't be as good as code, without the open source ecosystem. So it's kind of like a little bit of. That's certainly sure. Sure. Maybe is open source dead? Maybe. But like that's ironic because the fact that these models are so good is due to the fact that they had a corpus of open source code to train on. But that doesn't mean that open source isn't dead, right? Like, I think I said on a past podcast, like, anyone that's like working on some niche
现在AI来了，AI基本上复制了外面一半的开源项目。开源死了吗？这是一个有趣的问题。你看，如果没有开源生态系统，这些模型是不可能存在的，或者至少代码不会这么好。所以这有点像是。那是肯定的。当然。也许开源死了？也许吧。但这很讽刺，因为这些模型之所以这么好，是因为它们有开源代码库来进行训练。但这并不意味着开源没有死，对吧？就像我在过去的播客中说的那样，任何在某个小众语言上工作，希望它能挤进前20名的人，那种语言并不像AI，你知道，对AI代码生成更有利。这就像是一个注定失败的事业。我认为这是一件非常令人悲伤的事情。如果你在一个语言上投入了十年或五年，而现在的情况是，我们甚至不再那么关心编程语言了。总之，所以我不认为这必然是那些反AI且不相信它的人。我认为更多的是因为人们反AI，是因为他们
language in hopes that it's going to like break into the top 20, that that language is not like a AI, you know, better for AI code gen. It's like a lost cause. And I think that's a really sad thing. If you were investing like a decade or half a decade in a language that now it's just like, well, we don't even really care that much about. programming language. Anyways, so I don't think it's necessarily like people that are anti-AI and don't believe it's a thing. I think it's more that like people are, people are anti-AI because they're
担心它会给社会带来的破坏。我想在那个视频里，如果不是那个Zig开发者，我也许记错了归属。但基本上要么是那个网络播客，有人说：我进入软件工程领域可不是为了提示LLM来为我生成代码。我进入这个领域是因为我喜欢精心雕琢代码的艺术。而现在，软件开发已经不是那么回事了。这对我的职业生涯以及我工作的意义意味着什么，你知道的，如果我不想坐在那里写提示词、架构系统，而不是亲手编写代码，那对我意味着什么？我没有答案。我只是觉得他提出的这一点很有趣，我以前真的没怎么想过。我自己也经历过一次微型的存在主义危机，心想：我真的喜欢编程吗？我以前真的以为我喜欢编程，但这个新东西甚至更好。我可以行动得更快。我不再那么在乎代码本身了。
worried about like the disruption that it's going to cause in society. And this and like I think in that video, if it wasn't the Zig guy, I'm, I could be misattributing this. But basically it was either that internet podcast where someone said like, I didn't get into software engineering to like prompt LLMs to generate me code. Like I got into it because I, I liked the art of like crafting code. And like now that's not what being a software developer is anymore. Like what does that mean for my career and for like my meaningfulness of like, you know, like if I don't want to sit there prompting and like architecting systems and not actually
不管怎样，所以，我猜我属于那种成功过渡到这种新风格的人。我还是很开心。你知道，我可能会更疲惫一点。我可能工作得更努力，但我仍然很高兴。但我认为有一大比例的开发者并不高兴。他们不高兴，比如通过提示词来操作这些LLM，这就好像，那又意味着什么？我们应该在乎吗？我的意思是，如果它是高效的，你接着说。
handcrafting the code myself, like what does that mean for me? And like I'm not, I don't have the answer. I just think it's an interesting like thing that he brought up that I hadn't really thought about it. I have had my own, like, mini existential crisis of being like, do I actually like programming? Like, I really thought I liked programming, but this new thing is like even better. I can move faster. I don't care about the code so much.
再说一次，我不知道他们是否能成功。好吧，这甚至不是关于他们能否成功的问题。这是一个关于，或者我猜这也许是一个伪命题。你只是在说这无所谓。这有点像核武器那回事，无论我们做不做，别人都会做。所以你只能上车，否则就会被抛在后面。我认为，未来仍会有专门手写代码、人工审查代码的角色，但我认为这种角色会大大减少。好吧，我想是的，但这并没有真正回答问题。问题是，我们是否应该关心那些感到难过的人，他们不能再写他们心爱的for循环和算法了？是的。我们是否应该关心那些在职业生涯中投入了大量资金、技能以及曾经满腔热忱的同事？
And anyway, so, like, I guess I fit into a bucket of people that manage to transition to this new style. And I'm still happy. You know, I might be a little bit more exhausted. I might be working harder, but I'm still happy. But I think that there's a huge fraction or percentage of developers that are not happy. They're not happy, like, prompting these. LLMs and it's just like what does that mean like should we care? I mean if it's effect if you go ahead.
因为这个行业的许多人都是因为充满激情才来到这里的。我们是否应该关心这种改变，并且是如此迅速的改变？是的，我们当然应该关心。当然应该。而且我认为，当我们对这一切感到如此兴奋时，很难对那个群体产生同理心。我想你和我，康纳，可能并没有这种视角，因为我们很高兴能处于这种架构模式中。而且对我来说，至少已经有很多年没有真正写过代码了。translated correctly.
Again, I don't know if they're going to make it. Well, it's not a question about whether they're going to make it or not. It's a question about like or I guess I guess maybe it's a moot point. You're just kind of saying like it doesn't matter. It's kind of like the nuclear thing or whatever like whether or not we do it or someone else is going to do it. So like you just have to get on the train or get left behind. I think that I think that there will continue to be roles for people writing code.
translated correctly.
manually reviewing code, but I think there will be a lot less of that. Well, I guess, but that doesn't really answer the question. The question is, should we care about the people that are sad and that, like, they don't get to write their, like, four loops and algorithms anymore? Yeah. Should we care about our colleagues who have, you know, invested a substantial amount in their career and now maybe skills and things that they're passionate about?
because a lot of people in this industry are very, came to it because they're passionate. Should we care that that may be changing and changing very rapidly? Yeah, of course we should care. Of course we should care. And I think it's hard when we have so much excitement about this to have empathy for that audience. And I think you and I, Connor, probably don't have perspective on it because we are, we're happy to be in this, like, architecting mode. And for me, at least, it's been many years since I was really writing code.
translated correctly.
myself because I think we've talked about it before in the podcast. You know, I've had these ergonomic issues over the years that have sort of naturally pushed me into more of an architect role. I couldn't just sit at a keyboard and spend 10 hours a day, you know, building stuff. Now I can do that again. So yeah, I'm very excited about that. I can understand how for other people who are at the keyboard, you know, hacking away 10 hours a day and who really enjoy that, how they could be very devastated by having that taken away. Especially I understand it because that's something that happened to me. I used to really enjoy that, and then I physically could no longer do that. And so I had moments where I was really very much in the throes of existential crisis because I was like, well,
我自己，因为我觉得我们在播客里之前也讨论过。你知道的，这些年来我一直有一些人体工学方面的问题，这自然而然地把我推向了更多架构师的角色。我不能只是坐在键盘前，每天花10个小时去写代码、构建各种东西。现在我又可以做到这一点了。所以是的，我对此感到非常兴奋。我能理解，对于其他人来说，他们坐在键盘前，每天疯狂敲代码10个小时，并且真的很享受这种过程，如果被剥夺了这一切，他们会感到多么崩溃。我特别能理解这一点，因为这也是发生在我身上的事情。我以前真的很喜欢那样，然后我身体上再也无法做到这一点了。所以我也曾经历过那种深深陷入生存危机的时刻，因为我在想，好吧，
this was my whole career. What am I going to do now? Right? Like, I've been there. I get it. I had times when my ergonomic issues first started coming up where I really thought I was going to have to find another job or another career because I would not be able to be successful because the thing that I was good at, which is writing code, you know, I couldn't do it anymore. But, you know, those fears did, in my case, prove to be unfounded because I was able to, you know, adapt, go into a bigger role, you know, a role where I'm more architecting and leading than writing code day to day. And, I mean, I guess with AI, I ended up working out. But, yeah, like, it was really rough. That period of my life was a very rough period of my life.
这就是我的整个职业生涯。那我接下来该怎么办？对吧？就像，我也经历过。我懂。在我的工学问题刚开始出现的那段时间里，我真的以为我必须去找另一份工作或另一个职业，因为我将无法获得成功，因为我擅长的东西——也就是编写代码，你知道的，我再也做不了了。但是，你知道的，就我而言，那些担忧最终被证明是毫无根据的，因为我能够适应，你知道的，进入一个更大的角色，一个我更多地从事架构和领导工作，而不是日复一日地编写代码的角色。而且，我的意思是，我想随着人工智能的出现，我最终还是挺过来了。但是，是的，真的很难。我人生的那段时期是我人生中非常艰难的一时期。
and it was very hard on me mentally, in addition to being like the tough on me and painful physically. So yeah, I feel for people who are on the other side of this, I don't know, I don't know how to help folks. And like to some degree, I think that as we progress down this timeline, you know, as we progress down the shift towards this agentic era, I think people do need to reassess if you are not happy
这不仅对我的身体造成了沉重的打击和痛苦，而且对我的精神状态也打击很大。所以，是的，我为那些正处于这一变革另一端的人感到难过，我不知道，我不知道该怎么帮助大家。而且在某种程度上，我认为随着我们沿着这条时间线前进，你知道的，随着我们向这个智能体时代转变，我认为人们确实需要重新评估，如果你对
working in the new ways in which we may work, you may need to find something that makes you happy. And I don't know what that is. I hope it continues to be like, you know, the same career path that you still have some stability, but that may not be the case for everybody. You know, if you're not happy working in this new way
以我们可能需要采用的新工作方式工作感到不高兴，你可能需要找一些能让你快乐的事情。我不知道那是什么。我希望它能继续像以前一样，你知道的，是你仍然拥有一定稳定性的那个职业道路，但这可能并不适合所有人。你知道的，如果你对以这种新方式工作感到不高兴，
and if the industry of manually writing code as a dying industry, then you may need to go find, and if you're, if you're finding it depressing and sad to be in that space, because the thing that you used to do is no longer is valued, then it might be time to go and figure out what else would you be passionate about. I don't know. I'm just rambling here. Well, I mean, I've got thoughts, but I'm curious to hear from Marco. What are your thoughts on all of this?
如果手动编写代码的行业是一个正在消亡的行业，那么你可能需要去寻找，如果你发现身处那个领域让你感到沮丧和悲伤，因为你过去常做的事情不再有价值，那么也许是时候去弄清楚你还能对什么充满热情了。我不知道。我只是在这里胡思乱想。好吧，我的意思是，我有一些想法，但我很想听听马可的意见。对于这一切，你有什么看法？
And also, too, I guess you've started, you've been, like, compressed, right? Like, you started programming for the first time, like, four years ago. And so, yeah, I'm curious. Like, what are your thoughts both, like, personally how you feel about this whole thing and also, like, more in general? Yeah, I think I would agree with you both in that, obviously, programming with AI is the future, and there's no way around that. People that use agents to program are orders of magnitude more efficient and more productive
而且，我也觉得你已经开始，你一直像是在被加速压缩，对吧？就像，你大概在四年前第一次开始编程。所以，是的，我很好奇。从个人角度你对整件事情的感受，以及更宏观的看法，你都有什么想法？是的，我想我会同意你们两个人的看法，很显然，使用人工智能编程是未来，这是无法回避的。使用智能体进行编程的人，其效率和生产力要高出几个数量级，
than people who don't. I mean, just this week, I did something that took me two days of working on it, like, not here and there, not fully on it, something that six months ago, just six months ago, would have taken me a whole week at least. And so there's no way around that. Someone that uses AI is going to be more productive than someone that doesn't. But then I also have this feeling that right now it's very fun and very interesting because of the novelty, because you have so many options, you can do so many things. But I can see a future where maybe the joy will be taken out of it. Because right now they're not good enough that they do everything.
而不用智能体的人则做不到。我的意思是，就在本周，我做了一件事，它花了我两天的工作时间，不是那种零零碎碎的做，而是全神贯注地做；而如果放在六个月前，仅仅在六个月前，这至少需要我整整一周的时间。所以这是无法回避的。使用人工智能的人就是会比不使用人工智能的人更有生产力。但与此同时，我也有这种感觉，现在由于新奇感，它非常有趣，也非常吸引人，因为你有那么多的选择，你可以做那么多的事情。但我能预见到未来，也许其中的乐趣会被剥夺。因为现在它们还不够聪明，无法为你做所有的事情。
for you. I tell it what to do and then I still need to know how to code myself because I need to look at what the AI has done and then judge whether that's what I wanted it to do or not. And for that, I need to be good at programming because I need to understand what the code is doing and whether the idea that I had is actually what the code is doing or whether there's a better way of doing it. So it kind of takes the boring part away, which is actually writing it, but I still have to have the taste in what good code is and have the good ideas. But maybe, in a year from now or five years from now, it's already better at me than that. I'll just say, I think you said something really key there, and maybe didn't even notice
我告诉它该做什么，然后我仍然需要自己懂怎么写代码，因为我需要看人工智能做了什么，然后判断这是否是我想要它做的事。为此，我必须精通编程，因为我需要理解代码在做什么，以及我的想法是否真的是代码所做的事情，或者是否有更好的方法来完成它。所以它剔除了无聊的部分，也就是实际编写代码的过程，但我仍然需要对什么是好代码有鉴赏力，并有好的想法。但也许，在一年后或五年后，它在这方面已经比我更强了。我只想说，我觉得你刚才说了一个非常关键的点，甚至可能你都没有意识到
that you said it. You said it took the boring part away, which was writing it. And so I think maybe that is like, you know, we view it as boring, or I wouldn't have necessarily said that writing code was boring, but like I was mainly doing it in C++. And I wouldn't say it's boring. I always said it was painful. And that's one of my theories is that, like, depending on the language you were coming from, if it was C++ or C++, you love these tools. You never, you don't have to sift through, you know, template error message. You just put it in a loop. The AI figures it out.
你说了这句话。你说它把无聊的部分拿掉了，也就是编写代码的过程。所以我想也许这就是，你知道的，我们认为它是无聊的，或者我以前不一定会说写代码是无聊的，但就像我主要是在用 C++ 进行开发。我不会说它无聊。我总是说它是痛苦的。这就是我的理论之一，就像，根据你使用的语言，如果是 C++ 或类似语言，你会爱死这些工具。你再也不用去筛选，你知道的，模板错误信息了。你只要把它放进一个循环里。人工智能就能搞定它。
Whereas if you were maybe a rust or a ruby or some language that was really pleasant to use with a really good ecosystem, that the fun part, you know, was writing the code. It wasn't necessarily, you know, and so you take that away. And anyway, so I feel like we're all in a group of folks that, you know, don't miss the typing of the, you know, the syntax. But I think some people actually really enjoyed that. Anyways, Bryce, you were going to respond to. But yeah, I think the question is that, will in five years the AI be better than us at basically everything?
而如果你用的是 Rust 或 Ruby，或者某些用起来真的很愉快、生态系统极好的语言，那么有趣的部分，你知道的，其实就是编写代码。它不一定，你知道的，所以你把那部分拿掉了。不管怎样，我觉得我们都在这样一群人当中，你知道的，他们并不怀念敲击那些，你知道的，语法。但我想有些人其实真的很享受那个过程。不管怎样，布莱斯，你刚才正准备回应。不过是的，问题在于，五年后人工智能在基本上所有事情上都会比我们更强吗？
And so where would our place will, where will our place be in that? Yes. So I'm recalling what I was going to say now. Yeah, significant amounts of babysitting are needed. You know, Connor, for a long time, there's been this trend where we've come on and talked about it. And I've, we've both been excited about AI. But my perspective has been like, oh, this this freaking thing. it keeps like I get so frustrated at it.
那么我们在其中会处于什么位置，我们的归宿在哪里？是的。现在我想起我要说什么了。是的，这需要大量的悉心照料。你知道的，康纳，很长一段时间以来，一直有这样一种趋势，我们一直在节目里谈论它。而且我，我们俩都对人工智能感到兴奋。但我的观点一直是，哦，这个该死的东西。它总是——我经常对它感到非常沮丧。
You know, I think we've talked about it a couple episodes about my like frustration and like I'll frequently I'll be, I'll tell it like, dude, come on. Like, do you think that was real? Like, I'm like passive aggressive with it. And I know this is not the best prompting style, but at this point, I just, I got to be me, you know. You know, like I'll tell like, you know, take this, take this crap out. Like, you know, what are you doing here? And like, when it, when it violates like agents.md or like some rules, that I've like clearly like written down.
你知道，我想我们在之前的几期节目中讨论过我对它的沮丧情绪，通常我会对它说，老兄，拜托。你觉得那样做对吗？就像我会对它进行被动攻击一样。我知道这不是最佳的提示词风格，但到了这一步，我只能做我自己，你知道的。你知道的，就像我会告诉它，你知道的，把这些垃圾删掉。你知道，你在这里干什么？而且，当它违反了 agents.md 或者我写得清清楚楚的某些规则时，
I'll like do like what you do as small children. Like did you read the directions that I gave you? Oh, you did? Why didn't you do them? And that makes me feel a little bit better about it. But yeah, I don't know how it's interesting. There's like a duality here because on the one hand, there's what I was talking about earlier with.
我就会像对待小孩子那样质问它：你读过我给你的说明吗？哦，你读过了？那你为什么不照着做？这让我感觉稍微好受了一点。但是，是的，我不知道它是怎么回事，这很有趣。这里有一种二重性，一方面，就像我刚才说的，
My colleague was saying that like everybody on his team is a new college grad or an intern because they get it. They get how to use that. And on the one hand, like, yeah, I think, like, you need to have the right mindset, and young people are more likely to have that right mindset. But on the other hand, the crimes that I have seen committed that I was able to catch because I have, you know, 10 to 15 years of experience, like, you know, I'm building this little, like, orchestration layer thing. And, you know, like, security is a
我的同事说他团队里的每个人都是应届毕业生或实习生，因为他们懂。他们懂得如何使用这个。一方面，是的，我认为，你需要有正确的心态，年轻人更有可能具备这种正确的心态。但另一方面，我所看到的那些漏洞，由于我有10到15年的经验，我能够将它们捕捉到。你知道的，我正在构建这个小型的编排层东西。而且，你知道的，安全性是一个
concern. And, like, this has been, this was pretty clearly laid out in the design document. So I, I don't read a lot of the code, but I spent two days just iterating on the design document with the AI. I had it draft it and then I had it redraft it and redraft it until like I was every line of the design document I read. Like every bullet of the design document I was comfortable with. Like I reviewed that very, very carefully. And like, you know, in particular, like the security section. Because again, this thing doesn't have access to any, you know, proprietary information. It's just like it's running in a sandbox. Nothing really that terrible can go wrong, but still, you know, best practices. And, you know, there was a very clear plan for
问题。而且，这在设计文档中已经写得很清楚了。所以，我并没有读很多代码，但我花了两天时间只和人工智能一起迭代设计文档。我让它起草，然后让它重新起草，再重新起草，直到设计文档的每一行我都读过。设计文档的每一个要点我都觉得没问题。我非常非常仔细地审查了这一点。而且，你知道的，特别是安全部分。因为再说一次，这东西无法访问任何，你知道的，专有信息。它只是在沙盒中运行。不会真的发生什么太糟糕的事情，但尽管如此，你知道的，最佳实践嘛。而且，你知道的，有一个非常明确的计划，关于
what stuff it needed to expose to the outside world. And it just completely ignored one part of that. And, you know, sure, if I had read every line of code, I would have noticed that, maybe, but there's no way I could have read every line of code. And so the reason that I noticed it is that, like, eventually I caught on to like a subtle detail about like the architecture when I was talking to it or like I was asking about some like subtle thing. And I just had an intuition where I was like wait, hang on a second. If it's saying that this works this way, then that means that like X, Y and Z and that almost certainly has to be super insecure. And keep in my, I have no background in, you know, software security, web services, etc. I just like have a bunch of general industry experience. So I sort of have a sense of like, you know, what could be a problem, what would not be a problem. I know it. I know it's least what I don't know. But somebody who's less experienced and who doesn't have all of the like war stories and scars that, you know, a more senior dev has, I don't know. I feel like they would maybe miss a lot of these things. But maybe it's the sort of thing where, you know, in the old day, in the old days, you would make those mistakes yourself. And then the horrible thing would happen,
它需要向外部世界公开哪些内容。而它完全忽略了其中一部分。而且，当然，如果我读了每一行代码，我可能会注意到这一点，但绝无可能让我去读每一行代码。所以我注意到它的原因在于，就像我最终在和它交流时捕捉到了关于架构的一个微妙细节，或者我在询问一些微妙的事情时。我有一种直觉，我觉得等等，等一下。如果它说这是这样工作的，那就意味着 X、Y 和 Z，这几乎肯定是非常不安全的。请记住，我没有软件安全、网络服务等方面的背景。我只是有一堆通用的行业经验。所以我对什么可能是个问题，什么不是个问题有一种感觉。我知道。我至少知道我不知道什么。但是一个经验较少、没有资深开发人员所拥有的那些战争故事和伤疤的人，我不知道。我觉得他们可能会漏掉很多这样的事情。但也许就是那种情况，你知道的，在过去的日子里，你会自己犯那些错误。然后可怕的事情就会发生，
you know, the security bug, the corrupting your database, etc., would happen. to you early on in your career, and it would be a learning experience. And maybe now it's just that, like, it's a lot quicker for you to make those mistakes, and maybe also you learn faster from it. But, like, I think that the people keep asking about like, okay, but like, how are people, how are young people going to learn if they're not writing the code themselves? Well, I think that if you just go in, like, vibe code something and it's like a huge big mess and, like, has a bunch of subtle bugs in it, like, you're a very very very very. You're a very going to reel a lot. Like, that's going to be a learnable experience, too. I don't know about you,
你知道的，安全漏洞、破坏你的数据库等情况，会在你职业生涯的早期降临到你头上，这将是一个学习的过程。也许现在的情况只是，你犯这些错误的速度快得多了，也许你从中学习的速度也更快了。但是，我觉得人们一直在问，好吧，那么，如果年轻人自己不写代码，他们将如何学习？嗯，我认为如果你直接去，比如用“凭感觉编程”（vibe code）弄出个东西，结果是一团大乱子，里面有一堆隐蔽的bug，那么你将，非常非常非常。你将会学到很多东西。那也将是一个极具教育意义的学习经历。我不知道你们怎么样，
but like early on in my career, I wrote some like messy, you know, piles of garbage too. And like, I learned from that. And I don't think that's any different. Like, I don't think that the learning process is that much different. Like, you're going to, you're going to make mistakes. You know, this is a thing that lets you make mistakes at a much faster rate. But you're, everybody's going to make mistakes as part of the learning process. Yeah. And I guess it depends on the kind of person you are. but like one of the things super early on with these tools that I started calling it or referring to them is it's the democratization of expertise. And I don't mean that with respect to code. I mean that with respect to a lot of other white-collar professionals that you might need at some point in your life that you have to pay money, you know, real estate agent, lawyers for real estate, taxes, etc.
但在我职业生涯的早期，我也写过一些乱七八糟的垃圾代码。我也从中吸取了教训。我不认为这有什么不同。我不认为学习过程有什么本质上的不同。你总是会犯错误。你知道的，这是一个能让你以快得多的速度犯错的工具。但每个人在学习过程中都会犯错。是的。而且我想这取决于你是哪种人。但这些工具带来的极早期现象之一，我开始称呼或指代它的是——这是专业知识的民主化。我这样说不是指代码方面的民主化。我是指你可能在生活的某个阶段需要的许多其他白领专业人士的民主化，你本来不得不为此花钱，你知道的，房地产经纪人、处理房产和税务等事务的律师。
If you are the kind of person that wants to dedicate a Saturday to becoming an expert and, you know, insert whatever, you can. Like this year, I basically filed my own taxes alongside my tax advisor. So, like, I have my tax advisor do it. But then at the same time, I was like, I'm pretty sure with these tools, you know, I can figure out how to file all the correct forms. Sure enough, like, I did a better job and, like, caught a bunch of things that, like, my tax advisor didn't even catch because I would just sit there with the model and be like, listen, this is my situation, like, enumerate the list of things that I could possibly be
如果你是那种愿意花一个星期六的时间来让自己成为某个领域的专家——随便插入什么领域——的人，你完全可以。就像今年，我和我的税务顾问一起基本上自己报了税。所以，我有税务顾问帮我处理。但与此同时，我在想，有了这些工具，你知道的，我完全可以弄清楚如何正确填写所有的表格。果不其然，我做得更好，而且还抓出了好几个连我的税务顾问都没有注意到的问题，因为我只是坐在模型旁边说，听着，这是我的情况，请把我可以作为应税收入扣减项列出来的所有可能事项的清单枚举出来。而你花了几百美元雇来在一年里帮你报税的税务顾问是不会去——我的意思是，从技术上讲，我想我可以和他们开个会，然后向他们抛出一连串问题。但根据我和税务顾问打交道以及建立关系的经验，除非你去那种定制的高端机构，否则你是得不到那种服务的。无论如何。所以我就这么做了，明年我打算自己报税，你知道的，有很多事情，你可以非常迅速地自学到原本需要外包给其他专业人士的专业知识。我的意思是，
filing as, like, taxable income reductions. And, like, your tax advisor that you're paying whatever X hundred dollars to, file for a single year is not going to, you know, I mean, technically I guess I could take a meeting with them and then I could pepper them with questions. But like in my experience from the people and the relationships that they have with their tax advisors, you don't get that kind of like service unless if you're going to some like bespoke place. Anyways. And so like I've done this like next year I plan to file my taxes on my own, you know, and there's like a ton of stuff where you can basically teach yourself very rapidly like the expertise that you would offload to some other professional. I mean,
仍然有些事情是你必须要找真人来做的。请务必查看节目shownotes，无论是在你的播客应用中，还是访问 ADSP thepodcast.com，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个可以让你留下想法、评论和问题的 GitHub 讨论链接。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的标语。
there's still some things that you're going to need actual actual people for. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
这不是我们的标语。我们的标语是“带有信息撒花的混乱”。让我给你一些财务建议。我不同意。我不同意你的建议，但请继续。有一句关于——天哪，让我看看能不能找到它。有一句关于——计算机不能为某事承担责任，所以不应该被允许做出决定的名言，我觉得这有点适用于不得不自己报税这个想法。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. Let me give you some financial advice. I disagree. I disagree with your advice, but go ahead. There's this quote about like, God, let me see if I can find it. There's this quote about like a computer cannot take responsibility for something so it should not be allowed to make a decision that I think is kind of applicable to the idea of having to file your taxes.
我付钱请人帮我报税的原因是，如果出了问题，我有一个可以怪罪的人。而且，你知道的，如果我的税务出现非常严重的错误，我有某种潜在的获得赔偿的途径，对吧？我有针对严重错误的保险和保护。如果你用人工智能报税，你就没有那种保护。所以我愿意为此花钱，不管我的税报得有多对或者多不对。是的，当然，当然，也许他们会漏掉东西。也许人工智能会帮我识别出他们在报税时漏掉的东西。但是，这其实更是让我继续付钱给他们的一个理由。
The reason I pay someone to file my taxes is that if something goes wrong, I have a person I can blame. And, you know, some, some potential ways of getting restitution if there's a very serious error in my taxes, right? That, that I have some, I have some insurance and protection from a serious error. And if you file your taxes with AI, you don't have that, that protection. And so I'm willing to pay the money for that, not, like, regardless of whether or not, of how correct or not correct my taxes are. Yeah, sure, sure, maybe they'll miss things. maybe AI will help me identify things that they missed in the taxes. But, like, that's actually even more of a reason for me to continue paying them.
因为，如果他们犯了错误，你知道的，我可以向他们指出。但是，如果我自己报税时犯了非常严重的错误，我就是唯一的责任人，而且我没有任何求偿途径。我不知道。我真的不理解。就像我说的，我确实不同意。但你的意思是，所以最坏的情况是人们会指控你逃税，然后你最终要进监狱？不，就像——
Because, like, if they do make mistakes, like, you know, I can point that out to them. But, like, you know, if something, if I made some very serious error filing the taxes on my own, I'm the only person responsible, and I have no course for restitution. I don't know. I don't really understand. And like I said, I do disagree. But you're saying, but, like, so what's the worst case that people are going to accuse you of committing tax fraud and you're going to end up in prison? No, like, like.
你在这里担心什么？如果发生了一个让我损失几万美元或几十万美元的税务错误，如果是一个会计帮我报税并导致了那个错误，我可以通过法律系统采取各种途径在某种程度上弥补我的损失。所以基本上你想说的是，如果有你本来该交的税，但因为你的顾问的原因你没交。你现在要通过法律系统迫使你的顾问为你支付这笔钱？这让我，这给其他人——这吃相太难看了，老兄。这吃相太难看了。这让我有了另一个应该承担责任的人，另一个负有责任的人，
What are you worried about here? If a tax error occurred that cost me like, you know, tens of thousands of dollars or hundreds of thousands of dollars, like an accountant filed my taxes and led to that error, like I have various ways through the legal system that I could go about recouping to some degree my costs. So basically you're going to say if there was taxes that you owed, but because of your advisor, you didn't pay them. You're now going to force your advisor via the legal system to pay it for you. It gives me, it gives me somebody else who's a bad look, man. It's a bad look. It gives me somebody else who is culpable, somebody else who is on the line,
负责做这件事的人，如果他们犯了错误。我们可能会把这个税务板块的内容放到片尾曲之后作为彩蛋内容。它可能会变成片尾曲之后20分钟的内容。但是，呃，求求你了，求求你了，康纳，请不要，请不要依赖你的，请不要完全依赖人工智能来报税。不，不，不，不。
who is responsible for doing this thing. And that if they make a mistake. We might make this tax section bonus content after the outro. It might be a 20 minute after the outro. But, uh, please, please don't, Connor, just please don't rely on your, Please don't rely on AI solely to file your taxes. No, no, no, no.
关键在于这个。我自己报税。就像，我自己做所有的计算。我只是在和人工智能对话。就像，老实说，我认为……我收回刚才的话。我宁愿你用人工智能来做所有的报税，也不愿你自己花时间去计算税款。
That's the thing. I file my own taxes. Like, I do all the calculations. I'm just talking to the AI. Like, there's just like, honestly, I think the... I take it back. I would rather have you use AI to do all the taxes than have you spend time calculating the taxes yourself.
不，不，不。这就是重点。我曾经是一名精算师。我很喜欢电子表格。在我的税务状况变得非常复杂之前，我曾经很喜欢自己报税。老实说，如果你的税务状况很简单，报税是极其简单的。自从在英伟达工作以来，我的情况就再也不简单了，因为他们是一家美国
No, no, no. And that's the thing. I'm a former actuary. Like, I love spreadsheets. Like, I used to love doing my taxes before my tax situation got really complicated. And honestly, like, filing your tax. is incredibly simple if you have a simple situation. I do not have a simple situation ever since working for Nvidia because they're an American
公司。而且我获得报酬的方式是通过各种不同的薪酬机制。所以情况变得复杂了。我把它外包出去了。但现在有了人工智能，而且最主要的是，有些特定的表格，如果你不填写这些表格，可能会让你付出荒谬金额的罚款代价。
corporation. And like the way I get compensated, it comes through like different various whatever compensation mechanisms. And so it got more complicated. I offloaded it. But now with AI, like, and the main thing is, is like there are certain specific forms that like if you do not fill out that form, it can cost you like ridiculous amounts in terms of like fines.
但只要你确保填好了所有这些表格，就再也没有后顾之忧了。再也没有后顾之忧了。所以这就是我想说的，算是为你辩护吧，尽管你在美国为一家美国公司工作。所以事情不应该那么棘手。但如果是必须支付的罚款，而不是过去欠下的税款，而是他们对你征收的罚款，那我想你可以去找税务顾问。不管怎样，我们扯得太远了，因为我无意中提到了税收。只是恰好四月刚过去。美国的报税截止日是4月15日。
But like once you make sure you got all those forms, and there's no worry anymore. There's no worry anymore. So that's the thing that like, I guess in defense of you, although you're working in the States for an American company. So it shouldn't be that tricky. But it's that if there was like a fine that you ended up having to pay, not taxes that you owed in the past, but like a fine that they're levying on you, then I guess you could go after the tax advisor. But anyways, we got way off in the weeds because I mentioned taxes accidentally. It just happens to be April just passed. April 15th is for the Americans.
加拿大的报税截止日是4月30日？我们现在在干嘛？我们聊完人工智能了吗？我们现在要讨论GPU轮换了吗？我们要回答听众的问题吗？堆栈里还有第三个话题。MVP 竞赛。是的，我们要把谈话引向何方？
April 30th is for the Canadians? What are we? Are we done with AI? Are we talking about GPU rotate now? Are we answering questions from the people? There was some other third topic on the stack. The MVP comp. Yeah, what are we taking this conversation?
对，我们应该转向 GPU 轮换。对，也许我们也可以这样做，刚刚发生的那段，因为那是在什么，第 50 分钟、第 46 分钟左右。我敢肯定我们会因为这集节目而失去一些听众。没关系。税务相关的内容现在是彩蛋内容了，它会在片尾曲之后播出，我会加一个小标记，我们在
Yeah, we should rotate to GP rotate. Yeah, maybe what we'll do too is this episode that just happened, because that was at the what, 50, 46 minute mark. I'm sure we're going to lose listeners over this episode. That's all right. the tax stuff is now bonus content it's going to be after the outro and I'll put some little thing and we got a little get lost in
你知道的，税务对话中迷失了方向，如果你关心的话，你知道，就听听；如果不关心，随时可以停下来。那部分马上就来，我只想说这个：我用税务情况举例，重点不在于税务情况的具体例子，而在于更普遍的原则，即为什么有些事情我宁愿花钱请专业人士来做，即使我自己也能做，仅仅是因为花钱请专业人士意味着我找到了另一个承担责任的人，如果搞砸了，我可以去找那个人并获得赔偿。我明白了。你有——我的意思是，如果这就是你的运作方式，我理解。不过我的看法是，我认为唯一会最大程度地关心你的财务状况——真正最大程度地关心它的人——只有你自己。
the you know a tax conversation if you care you know listen if you don't feel free to stop. That one's going to come I'll just say this the point I'm making with the tax situation is less about the specific example of the tax situation. It's more about the general principle of why I there are
一旦你开始把事情外包给别人，他们现在首先也是最优先考虑的是他们自己，而不是你。也许你有一个极好的财务顾问、税务顾问或其他什么顾问，或者也许他们是你的家人或好朋友。什么？信任但要核实。嗯，这就是问题所在。如果我要去核实并替他们完成全部工作，那我一开始为什么还要付钱给他们？
certain things that I prefer to pay a professional money for even if I could do them myself just because paying the professional money for it gives me somebody else who's responsible where if there's a fuck up, I can go to that person and there can be restitution. I see. Have you. I mean, if that's if that's the way that you operate, I understand. My thing, though, is I think that there's the only person that will maximally care about like your financial well being, like maximally care about it is you. As
因为由我自己去核实别人的工作成果，付出的工作量要少一些。这和人工智能是一样的。就像，与其让我写一万行代码，不如让我去审查和审计一万行代码，去审查我的税务会计或律师等提交的 PR，这所耗费的精力要少得多。我宁愿这样做，也不愿自己从头到尾把它全做完。我不知道，我的意思是，在某些情况下，我认为这是真的。
soon as you start outsourcing to someone else, like they are now looking out for themselves, first and foremost, not for you. Like, maybe you have an amazing financial advisor, tax advisor, whatever other advisor, but like, or maybe if they're in your family or they're a good friend. What? Trust but verify. Well, that's the thing. If I'm going to verify and do their whole job for them, why am I paying them in the first
在这个具体的例子中，我的“核实”基本上就像我说的，是我自己把整个过程重新复制了一遍。不管怎样，我们不聊了，不聊了。没人关心。没人关心。我们是不是因为人工智能的热门观点而失去了听众？当然。
place? Because it's less work for me to verify a work product by somebody else. This is the same thing with AI. Like, instead of me writing 10,000 lines of code, it's less effort for me to review an audit a 10,000 lines of code, to review a PR from my tax accountant or my lawyer or whatnot. I'd rather do that than have to go and do it all myself. I don't know if, I mean, in certain cases, I think that's true.
百分之百。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。
In the case of this specific example, my, like, verifying was basically just, like I said, replicating the whole process myself. Anyways, we're down, we're down. Nobody cares. Nobody cares. Did we lose listeners over the AI hot take? Certainly.
就这个具体例子而言，我的验证方式基本上就像我刚才说的，是我自己把整个过程重新复现了一遍。不管怎样，我们完蛋了，我们完蛋了。没人关心的。没人关心的。我们是不是因为那个关于人工智能的热门言论而失去听众了？肯定的。
100%. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
百分之百。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。